[Music]
benjamin netanyahu
israel's prime minister has been a
powerful force in global politics
for the past 12 years his devotees call
him the king of israel
but in recent years netanyahu has faced
repeated government collapses
and accusations of corruption bribery
and fraud
benjamin netanyahu was back before a
judge a short time ago saying he's
not guilty now the ruling coalition in
israel has collapsed
now israel is holding its fourth
election in just two years
so for him staying in the prime
minister's chair has become
something of an existential question how
will this election
mark a shift in israel's political
future
you submitted your questions to anshul
feffer the economist's jerusalem
correspondent
and greg carlstrom middle east
correspondent
here are their answers how is netanyahu
doing in the polls
the gamble that he took a few months ago
when he engineered these
early elections uh was that by the end
of march
israel would have rushed ahead with
kovitz 19 vaccinations it would have
been able to lift lockdowns and
return the economy uh to being open and
the people would be
euphoric and happy about this and that
it would pay political dividends for
netanyahu
and of course some of that has happened
that it hasn't paid the sorts of
political dividends that netanyahu hoped
it would
uh you know you look at the the polls
over the past few weeks past couple of
months
and he's sort of consistently coming in
at around 30 seats or less so a quarter
or less
of the seats in the knesset where he
would have preferred i'm sure to be
somewhere closer to at least 40 seats uh
so again yes it will come down to a
situation where
it matters whether one or two small
parties cross the threshold to make the
knesset or not it matters
whether parties pick up one extra seat
or lose one extra seat it could come
down to a very small margin
how did netanyahu remain in power after
the corruption charges
well the israeli law isn't exactly clear
on
what are the circumstances under which a
prime minister has to resign
there isn't that there are laws and
precedents under which ministers need to
resign if they're indicted
on criminal charges but since the
resignation of the prime minister would
mean
the replacement of the entire government
that is not uh required
and since netanyahu has now been
indicted on charges of bribery and fraud
has been tested and we and israel has a
serving prime minister
who is also in court facing these
charges
um you would expect the political
establishment to get together and force
out a prime minister
under these circumstances but the
israeli political status is very weak
right now
it's split into many parties netanyahu's
own party
is completely under his control and his
allies
also have an interest in him remaining
in the
imposition so it's been impossible to
force netanyahu to resign
what will happen with netanyahu's
corruption charges
if he becomes prime minister again so
13 days after the election on
april the 5th and senior is actually
scheduled to be back in court
and whatever happens in the election
that session in court
isn't it won't go away it won't
disappear but what netanyahu does hope
if he does manage to gain a majority in
the next knesset
is that he'll have finally uh enough for
supporters for a law which could
uh grant him immunity from prosecution
while
while he's serving prime minister
another thing he'd like to do is he'd
like to fire or replace
and replace the attorney general who's
brought these charges and
appointed that position someone who may
uh
decide to revisit the charges but right
now he's on track
to go back into court he's the defendant
while being the serving and perhaps also
the next prime minister right and that
goes back to this question
of why israel keeps going to election
after election it's because netanyahu if
he were to
lose power if he were to relinquish his
grip on the premiership
uh he doesn't have these avenues to try
and block or or
end the corruption trial against him he
would be just an ordinary member of
parliament he would be ineligible to
serve as a minister
and he would lose the ability to try and
steer through a law that
grants him immunity or try to remove the
attorney general
and so for him staying in the prime
minister's chair has become
something of an existential question
what explains the crisis in government
that led to this election and those in
2019 and 2020
for the last two years netanyahu despite
being the serving prime minister hasn't
had
a majority in israel's parliament the
knesset
supporting his government and that's
been a situation
also basically since the the end of 2018
and following the last three elections
the parties supporting him
have failed to gain a majority despite
the opposition in two of these elections
having
on paper a majority which supported the
challenger
in in those three elections uh benny
gantz
those parties failed to uh to
to work together partly for reasons of
the
major political diversity between them
israel's basically been in political
limbo now for two years and that's why
israel is now having its fourth election
in less than two years
what has netanyahu been like as prime
minister for the past 12 years
well i think for the past 12 years
netanyahu's continued
rule we've seen in israel an increasing
tendency
on his side towards i wouldn't say a
full autocracy but certainly
very much a presidential type of of
administration which is not israel's
uh political system is also
parliamentary system wherever netanyahu
has increasingly ignored both the
ministers of his cabinet
and his partners in coalition has really
evolved into almost a one-man rule and
we've seen it
uh over over the last 12 years and
especially in the last 12 months
during uh the coral virus pandemic in
which nathaniel has basically
run the show with a very very small
handful of advisors and without
whenever he can without advising the
cabinet you're increasingly seeing
an evolution in how politics are
conducted in a way
the entire government is revolving
around one figure around netanyahu
and i think you see that broadly not
just with israel's domestic politics but
with its foreign relations as well
the relation with the gulf states
carried out without the knowledge of
israeli ministers much of the sensitive
diplomacy with arab states is being done
by yoshi cohen the mossad director
who reports directly to the prime
minister even the relationship with
russia netanyahu and vladimir putin
speak
personally on a regular basis the
israeli foreign ministry to some extent
feeling marginalized in israel's foreign
relations at least when it comes to
some of these key relationships with
regional players and global powers
it's become very centralized under one
man
who will most likely be the next prime
minister if netanyahu loses
there are a number of challengers or
would-be prime ministers who
are hoping to replace netanyahu uh
according to the polls the one with the
at least with the biggest party after
liquid ms
lapid the centrist politician former
journalist and chat show host who's been
already for nine years in politics
trying to build uh
a base in the center ground which is
which he's succeeding in doing however
he hasn't really managed
to break beyond that sort of that block
of centrist voters and to
make to make any any headway further
into the right where most of the israeli
voters
are right now there are two other
challenges on the right there's
naftali bennett a former aide netanyahu
a former minister
in his government who who is the leader
of a smaller
right-wing party and he may even emerge
as a king maker in this election
he could he could be the one holding the
balance between a majority for the
netanyahu bloc
or for an alternative coalition so he
certainly is a is a contender for prime
minister
and the third contender is uh gideon
sarah another former liquid minister
who broke away from liquid just three
months ago and set up a party which is
basically
another liquid just like which is
against netanyahu to be another prime
minister in israel first of all
they have to work out a way to work
together
and to find a majority that will appoint
one of them
as prime minister and that's going to be
their biggest obstacle deciding which of
them
will be the leader of this new block and
of course the one person
who will absolutely not be the next
prime minister is benign who was the
main opponent
to netanyahu in the previous two
elections who ultimately after the
previous election
uh joined the unity government formed a
coalition with
netanyahu he is one of this ever
rotating caste of centrist or
center-left political figures who have
tried to challenge
netanyahu over the past decades but as
an shell said they've always
struggled to find a way to to work
together and to bring together this very
uh heterogeneous group of parties that
might like to see netanyahu out but
can't agree on much more than that how
will foreign policy change
if netanyahu loses the election
well i think if you look at certainly
the relationship with
america which is israel's most important
foreign relationship
netanyahu has had difficult relations
with democratic administrations going
back
uh decades many democrats are angry with
him not only because he was close to
donald trump but because he was openly
antagonistic towards the obama
administration also
netanyahu and democratic governments
have have not worked well together
historically and so i think in terms of
relations with america a different prime
minister
would be seen as a welcome change in
washington that being said i don't know
if it solves any of the
structural problems in the relationship
between america and israel
the next israeli prime minister whoever
it is unlikely to be
a full-throated supporter of biden's
stated policy of wanting to re-enter the
nuclear deal with iran
unlikely to do much uh vis-a-vis
diplomatic engagement with the
palestinians so
you have an influential faction within
the democratic party that
uh is quite critical of israel's policy
towards the palestinians and they won't
be mollified
i think by a change of administration in
jerusalem
could a new israeli leader find a
compromise with the palestinians
i think it's it's very striking when you
watch an israeli election campaign
because if you're
outside of israel where the
israeli-palestinian conflict
is still something that commands a lot
of attention be it in the west or in the
middle east
there's this sense or this expectation
that it might also be an issue a big
issue in israel that it should be a big
issue there
and it's not really when it comes to
electoral campaigns this is not
something that comes up people talk
about
the economy they talk about questions of
religion and state they talk
increasingly about netanyahu and the way
he governs
but the palestinians are just not an
issue that comes up on the campaign
trail and
there's not going to be much pressure
for the next israeli government whoever
is in charge of that government
uh to change policy towards the
palestinians uh and a change in
leadership
is not going to change the the
structural reasons why
there's been no progress towards any
sort of a deal
i don't see any of that changing with a
change of administration
in israel if netanyahu remains in power
how likely is annexation of the west
bank
well netanyahu promised in the past
three elections the two elections of
2019 and the one of 2020
various versions of annexation in the
west bank he spoke about
different parts of the west bank that he
would like to what he calls to extend
sovereignty to and these were
in essence uh election promises but i
don't think netanyahu ever really
intended to uh to carry carry this out
we didn't see once the elections were
over any concrete steps
towards annexation and even then though
netanyahu spoke about it and it was even
mentioned
in his coalition agreement with benny
gantz
it never happened i'm greg carlstrom
the economist middle east correspondent
thanks for watching and you can learn
more about israel's election by
clicking the link opposite don't forget
to subscribe